et si vous me suivez en direct un
reportage qui vous a sans doute ouvert
l'appétit pour préparer ensuite votre
repas du soir la chronique culture à
présent avec johanna soudry bonsoir je n
ai rien vu et ce soir on découvre une
chorale ukrainienne est oui alors pour
nous en parler
vassil boris vous êtes vous-même
ukrainien vous êtes le chef de choeur de
la chorale a alors à corinne y voilà et
à côté d'où la présidente donc de
l'association sylvie chemin roy alors
d'où vient le nom justement que j'ai eu
du mal à prononcer le nom de la chorale
s'est pas du tout et craignant pas du
tout à corinne y signifie atelier
chorale de saint quentin en yvelines
c'est une association qui a maintenant
quinze années d'existence elle a été
crée donc en 1997 par soultz ont la
volonté de 15 salariés qui travaillaient
dans les entreprises de saint quentin
avec à leur tête monsieur rené tronche
qui a assuré la présidence jusqu'au mois
de juin de cette année date à laquelle
j'ai pris la succession voilà alors
toute la chorale est composée de
français à part le chef de choeur qui
eux craignent un et une personne aussi
je crois qu'il est d'origine ukrainienne
absolument oui
revenons tout le monde est français ce
qu'il faut par les ukrainiens pour
chanter en italie c'est moi qui aie qui
verrait pour le fun je suis la française
de de votre représentation ce soir
non c'est pas utile de parler ukrainien
toutes nos partitions se retrouvent sont
retranscrites en phonétique et vassil
est là bien entendu pour rectifier les
prononciations quand le besoin se fait
sentir quand ça va il s'en sortent
c'est doit en rire certains appelant au
plaignant véritablement un certain wind
certains vient avec ses dictionnaires
les plus réguliers du coi sépare les
chansons pas de méthode propre salon
vous êtes mais aussi n'ont pas encore
pendant qu'on est là et on recommence
encore voilà absolument donc qui sait
qui se cherche justement de transcrire
en phonétique les paroles c'est
vous-même et oui je peux dire avec mme
enfin parce que ma femme est française
et donc le soir comme comment un petit
peu le temps donc j'ai vraiment ça les
clients français
là je commence à faire de plus du tout
seul et vous traduis traduisait aussi
parce que c'est important d'avoir
l'interdiction absolue mans me oui il
n'est pas chanter c'est bien je suis
hantée en ukrainien c'est parfait mais
autant savoir un petit peu ce que l'on
interprète mal à la traduction des
champs et ça nous l'avons bien entendu
alors si lui comment vous est venu voir
ce type de chants qui n'est pas commun
ah non c'est pas du tout comme un j'y
suis venu par hasard tout à fait par
hasard lors d'un forum des associations
où j'ai rencontré un ami qui m'a vanté
les mérites et les bienfaits de cette
chorale j'avais chanté dans une
lointaine jeunesse je faisais partie de
chorales et mais j'ai été attiré par ses
chants ukrainiens parce que mon ami
d'enfance et d'origine ukrainienne
donc j'avais entendu beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup parlé de l'ukraine et je me
suis dit pourquoi pas j'ai fait un essai
et puis voilà c'était cesse afin faire
la 5ème saison qu'il se concrétise enfin
si vous vous êtes en france depuis
plusieurs années
on verra tout à l'heure dans le
reportage un petit peu ce qui vous a
amené en france
vous êtes à l'origine accordéoniste
n'êtes pas chef de choeur non alors ça
c'est fait
et côté je claque dans beaucoup de
métiers ont commencé choses à faire
ensemble qu'en vérité
c'est là que chef de choeur les chefs
d'orchestre au départ j'étais un
communiste et chef d'orchestre
d'instruments traditionnels et donc
voilà c'est pas très loin mais c'est
quand même différent différents mais si
je me présentais c'était l'occasion de
diriger à nicolas et à l'étranger dirigé
aux colonies chorale qui vais chanter en
locaux n'y a juste ne se refuse pas mais
cela dit vous n'avez pas abandonner le
lac ordures on vous voit voilà et
j'étais justement en fait justement j'ai
trouvé ça original parce qu'en plus je
comprendre certaines chansons moi même
la carte dans quels sont les instruments
justement qu'on va retrouver dans l'est
dans les chants ukrainiens l'accordéon
le piano peut-être ébats pernaut c'est
pour travailler c'est vrai que notre
répertoire
c'est beaucoup musiques traditionnelles
populaires et pernod s'est pas toujours
le cas et par contre ce qui est
intéressant on a fait collaboration avec
des musiciens
de différents instruments qui venaient
au 2e classe ou sinon j'ai trouvé
quelques quelques amis mais c'est un ici
donc tout d'un coup qu'il nous
accompagne satan voilà vous êtes arrivé
en 2006 à la chorale c'est ça je ferai
oui au début quand vous êtes arrivé il
n'y avait que que entre guillemets 25
choristes et maintenant il y en a 60
plus de 60 même qu'est ce qui plaît
autant dans les chants slaves gaieté ses
joyaux et je sais pas en fait il faut
demander des décos liste qui soufflait
vraiment c'est la joie ou qu'on dit
toujours lan cela mais c'est vrai que ça
ça se ressent dans les champs que ce
soit dans les chants sacrés que les
chants populaires également il ya
quelque chose qui se dégage qu'on ne
retrouve pas dans les autres champs
alors on est allé vous su pendant une
répétition
c'était cette semaine à guyancourt dans
la maison cartier mendes et là vous
répéter toutes les semaines et on a
rencontré brigitte qu'un peu le même
parcours que vous
brigitte chante en langue slave depuis
cinq ans c'est aujourd'hui elle est
choriste accords unis c'est un peu par
hasard
j'étais venue au forum parce que pour
autre chose pour tout à fait autre chose
et je suis passé devant port à l'accord
signé en ukraine
je suis arrêté je suis pas reparti pour
brigitte les champs et craignent un sont
un véritable coup de coeur malgré les
guerres malgré les famines malgré tout
ce qu'ils ont pu vivre
il se relève toujours et la plupart du
temps en chantant les ukrainiens sont
capables de passer du champ le plus
triste est le plus profond comme
peut-être celui que vous avez entendu
tout à l'heure où une mère leur son fils
et ses larmes font pousser un arbre
bon et alors à la gaîté met
instantanément
il passe du rire aux larmes c'est je
crois ce qu'on appelle l'âme slave la
chorale répète assidûment leur concert
de noël sous la direction artistique de
vinci d'un chef de choeur il faut dire
que je me demande pour les ukrainiens
quelque chose particulière parce que est
en fait dans l'époque et que exister
entre l'urss
donc c'était les champs qui étaient
interdits ou presque interdite
et là donc nous on a chanté en question
en cachette
donc voila moi je connais tout ça et
pour moi ça fait quelque chose
supplémentaire c'est pas une chambre
normale mais quelque chose on peut
chanter les bleus mois on peut montrer
aux autres gens
oh
bassil a reçu une formation initiale
d'accordéonistes alors qu'il vient se
produire dans l'hexagone il rencontre sa
future épouse habitante de la ville de
plaisir si la musique l'a fait venir en
france c'est l'amour qui l'a fait rester
pourtant
m
là
la chorale de chants ukrainiens donnera
un concert en l'église de garantir le 15
décembre à 20 heures avant un concert de
noël en janvier à l'église chrétienne de
pabu
amusant si lui parce que dans le
reportage on a vu une autre choristes
brigitte qui disait un petit peu la même
chose que vous venez vous ne vous êtes
pas concertés ça je peux vous l'assurer
alors on a vu aussi un choeur mixte des
hommes et des femmes mais une fois que
le choeur mixte le travail est fini il
n'y a que les hommes qui restent et les
femmes s'en vont pour chanter seul bar
ça vient d'où cette tradition est en
fait battre à 10 ans en fait c'était
c'était déjà comme ça on est dans
l'époque que j'allais à la chorale donc
les hommes et les travailler un peu mais
son centre est là ou plus donc voilà je
trouvais que c'était très bien et les
femmes ne chante pas seul c'est ce que
disent et j'aimerais bien à chanter
toujours un peu et chanter les femmes et
les enfants c'est au sein de cours ni il
y a trois que rien choeur mixte slave
que vous avez entendu lundi soir un
choeur d'hommes de chants slaves
également que vous avez entendu et le
mardi nous avons des répétitions de
chants d'europe chants populaires et
traditionnelles d'europe
non mais c'est malheureusement ce
répertoire n'est est en cours de
construction
donc il ne sera pas présent sur scène
pour cette saison artistique d'accord
alors on vous a vu aussi dans le
reportage vous aviez vous ne portez pas
de costumes traditionnels mais alors
vous va si là je vais faire un
commentaire sur votre chemise et ça
c'est une génisse très positif c'est
plutôt sympa aussi c'est une belle
chemise chemise là maintenant faire avec
on fait donc voilà je suis très très
heureux de porter et de suivi est une
traditionnelle chemise claire de ma
région
nous ce que nous créons et là on va dire
qu'il a des costumes traditionnels et la
plus heureuse je pense que la plus
qu'avant que ce tournoi est donc voilà
ça c'est de deux mâts de ma région c'est
un peu beaucoup de rouge beaucoup de
blanc rouge et beaucoup de figures
géométriques mon nom à travers la
chorale justement vous parlez de la
culture parler du pays vouloir tout à
fait
c'est à dire tout à fait ouais ça va et
c'est là que à travers de deux champs de
culture on parle du style et des choses
et des choses
guèye comme on a dit tout à l'heure mais
aussi des choses profondes qui s'en va
et on avait rencontre avec un cinéaste
qui fait filmé ce au sénat français qui
fait film sur lot de morts par exemple
et c'est un époque historique très très
difficile pour nous prononcer les
connaît une crise c'est quand même un
pic a beaucoup souffert voilà alors plus
récemment il ya eu déjà nos villes entre
autres en prêt lui aussi toute la
domination soviétique
tout ça se ressent vraiment il ya des
chants qui sont en train de de 7,7 à
tristesse mélancolie où ces temps
difficiles il a beaucoup en fait c'est
vrai que dans notre répertoire est
claire deschamps est qui qui parle de ce
sujet là par exemple ou sinon les
impacts de tout ça il a des deschamps
avec les sujets historiques mémoire de
tous comme ça mais c'est pas le but
faire de politique quel que soit le
doute s'est montré le culture d'impunité
voilà ça fait plaisir et partager vous
voyagez aussi beaucoup vous avez déjà
voyagé en ukraine vous allez bientôt
partie du pays bas oui nous avons donné
des concerts en ukraine nous avons
d'abord reçu
nous sommes d'abord allés aller en
ukraine où nous avons été reçus par une
chorale et nous avons donné quelques
concerts avec elle ces chorales a été
reçu chez nous après guyancourt
après nous avons été en contact avec une
chorale des pays bas qui s'appelle la
chorale lyssenko également qui chante la
musique traditionnelle byzantine
nous avons reçu cette année est donc là
début décembre nous partons si ce n'est
quelques quelques concerts et donc en
janvier on pourra également vous
retrouver en concert à l'église
ukrainienne de paris c'est un concert
qui est ouvert à tous absolument c'est a
ouvert à tous c'est le dimanche 27
janvier en début d'après midi à l'église
ce saint vladimir le grand boulevard
saint-germain à paris par l'acea tous
les deux d'être venus ainsi johanna
prochaines pages culture mercredi
prochain au même horaire vous aimez le
hard rock
j'avais intérêt parce qu'on a quatre
représentants d'un groupe yvelinois de
hard rock et qui vont venir sur le
plateau dans un instant et qui vont nous
parler de la préparation de leur
prochain album auparavant le mois de
novembre le mois des plantations dans le
domaine national de marly 222 dit elles
sont plantées à terme ce sont 5000
arbres qui vont revenir peupler ce lieu
royal est ce que ça vous plaît comme
numéro 4 quand même il fallait bien sûr
c'est 90 c'est sous la pluie et dans un
sol boueux que les premiers tilleuls du
domaine de marly ont été replantés jadis
résidence du roi louis xiv le domaine de
marly fut rachetée en 1811 par napoléon
depuis 2009 le site appartient au
château de versailles s'étaler descend
de la grille royale ce qui est l'arrivée
depuis versailles pour les cortèges
royaux et descend jusqu'au pavillon du
roi et donc ces deux grands murs qui ont
été construits là le retiennent
complètement les collines de part et
d'autre trois mètres 32 auteurs quand
même des murs de deux mètres d'épaisseur
construite dès l'origine avec cette
fonction de soutènement et les arbres
pousser sans son contrôle
donc ils ont atteint des hauteurs que
vous voyez autour de nous de les racines
dégrader les murs de soutènement et il y
avait en plus un risque avec des coups
de vent ou les où la chute des arbres
arrachés complètement le mur ajoutez à
cela la tempête de 99 qui avait dévasté
les crêtes de marly en emportant 1500
arbres aucun chantier de remise en état
n'avait été entrepris avant aujourd'hui
première étape la campagne d'abattage
nous en avons l'an dernier a battu 750
quand je parle d'arbres je ne parle pas
de jeunes végétaux je parle d'un massif
donc c'était une campagne extrêmement
difficile
je dirais senti mentalement parce que
nous aimons les arbres 222 tilleuls
seront replantés le long de l'allée
royale selon les plans de louis xiv pour
une restitution parfaite nous pourrons
voir le gazon et les premiers arbres
avec quelques bourgeons au printemps
prochain et donc ça sera aussi un
hommage à le nôtre que de faire revivre
cette partie là du parc
le château lancera une campagne
d'adoption des tilleuls plantés
le public pourra ainsi parrainé un arbre
dans la somme de 1000 euros pour
l'automne 2012 1500 végétaux
supplémentaires seront introduits dans
le parc de marly de même à l'automne
objectif final sur 5000 arbres 2014 on
peut dire que la porte de paris sera
agréable dans 15 20 ans beau dans trente
ou quarante ans est superbe dans un
siècle
mais les équipes de versailles plantes
pour l'avenir et la postérité
les membres du groupe malatesta m'ont
rejoint bonsoir à tous les quatre on va
parler de hard rock yvelinois dans un
instant juste le temps de faire le point
sur les sorties ciné du jour vos avis à
la sortie des salles à l'issue des
nouvelles projections au micro d' elodie
moi j'étais voir nico de le petit renne
et franchement ça vaut vraiment le coup
d'y aller pour les enfants il est
vraiment bien fait c'était très bien
bah c'était sympa c'était plus pour les
petits mais c'était un film sympa sur
noël et sur les rênes et son histoire
c est un film avec beaucoup d'effets
spéciaux j'avais une petite préférence
sur pour le premier parce que c'était de
la nouveauté mais celui-là était
vraiment très bien moi je suis amateur
des films un peu à sensation jeu ça va
plus et c'était un très joli dessin
animé je pense que les filles ont bien
aimé on va 3 et 6 ans et c'était
vraiment très bien c'était bien et j'ai
aimé parce que y avait beaucoup de
bagarres mais avait un échange et il
s'était très bien fait populaire un très
très bon film et il mérite bien le label
qu'on lui a donné
alors j'ai trouvé ça très bien c'est
coloré c'est jovial en même temps c'est
très masculin quand kim parce que c'est
il ya beaucoup de forces à un
championnat pas raison quand elle
s'entraîne pour championnat de dactylo
et c'est très drôle